[Musik]
verbrannt verdorrt unfruchtbar immer
mehr gleich die algarve einer wüste
bauer jörg ihm ist verzweifelt
ich habe hier früher wasser und
honigmelonen und noch viel mehr
angepflanzt
mit hilfe einer kleinen motorpumpe
konnte ich wässern aber dieses jahr
musste ich aufgeben
seht ihr hier das ursprüngliche niveau
des wassers wo es früher lag
der grund für den hoffnungslosen zustand
seiner farm sei eine avocado plantage
die direkt nebenan errichtet wurde
sie verbrauchen da drüben so viel wasser
und mein brunnen ist nicht tief sie
saugen förmlich mein wasser in ihre farm
und hier versucht es einfach
bio ingenieuren claudia seal will genau
das wissenschaftlich belegen mit einem
lasermessgerät macht sie sich ein bild
von der wasser- situation in james brown
so rund drei meter der brunnen leert
sich früher lag der wasserstand rund
anderthalb meter höhe
am ende des sommers kontrollieren wir
wieder den wasserstand er wird niedriger
sein
wir wollen verstehen was hier passiert
und daten als beweise sammeln in anderen
ländern ist es pflicht solche daten für
neue bauprojekte zu rate zu ziehen in
portugal nicht man muss aber für ein
vorhaben wie eine neue plantage wissen
wie viel wasser der region zur verfügung
steht und ob die ressource weiter
belastet werden kann
und die belastungsgrenze scheint hier
längst erreicht die dürre in der algarve
ist groß im sommer brennen immer wieder
die wälder hinzu kommt nun der immense
wasserverbrauch der plantagen einer
vokabel baum verbraucht am tag in etwa
so viel wasser wie eine vierköpfige
familie
30.000 avocados werden täglich im land
produziert tendenz steigend doch nicht
nur der große durst der frucht sein
problem bemängeln kritiker auch der
einsatz von pestiziden sei eine echte
belastung für die region und für das
klima ganz anders sieht das
plantagenbesitzer hugo milliliter die
portugiesischen avocados seien nicht die
klimasünder als die man sie darstellt
findet er schon gar nicht sein für ihn
sind die europäischen plantagen er die
lösung eines klimaproblems
freeload.de avoca was ist denn mit den
abo kaders aus südamerika sie müssen 28
tage was sag ich 30 tage über den
atlantik verschifft werden der co2
fußabdruck dieser früchte ist doch viel
größer als der unserer sollten die alter
nicht lieber hier direkt in europa
produzieren
militär ist sich sicher seine avocados
haben keinen negativen einfluss auf die
umwelt und er lädt das kamerateam auf
seine plantage ein um es zu beweisen die
arbeitsbedingungen hier seien fair der
einsatz von pestiziden minimal und die
bewässerung auf das grundwasser dass die
brunnen der region speist sei seine
plantage gar nicht angewiesen
unsere region hier an der algarve wird
von zwei stauseen mit wasser versorgt
über ein rohrsystem erreicht es uns mit
hohem druck wir müssen also überhaupt
nicht auf brunnen zurückgreifen wir
nutzen im grunde genommen bloß
regenwasser
was uns hier fehlt sind weitere
staudämme
trotzdem dieses jahr hatten wir so viel
regen unsere stauseen sind fast bis zum
rand gefüllt wir haben wasser mindestens
für die nächsten zwei jahre
der plantagenbesitzer scheint sich die
nachhaltigkeit seiner farm zumindest
teilweise schönzureden beweisen claudias
ziel und ihre begleiterin sie suchen
einen der stauseen auch von den melitta
sprach zum zeitpunkt ihres besuchs
sollte hier eigentlich eine wassertiefe
von zehn metern herrschen doch er ist
fast leer
es hat seit jahren nicht genug geregnet
der wasserstand gibt jedes jahr zurück
immer etwas weniger als im vorjahr
auch wenn die leute behaupten es habe
viel geregnet vergangenen winter im
dezember oder november aber es war nicht
genug
das wasser hier im stau sie nutzen zum
größten teil örtlichen bauern die lage
ist derart angespannt dass sie anfangen
sich um das wasser regelrecht zu prügeln
bauern die neuen zu kommen und auch das
wasser nutzen wollen werden einfach
verjagt
verantwortlich für die regulierung des
wasserverbrauchs ist eigentlich das
staatliche umweltamt apa das aber sei
industrie in konsequenz bei der
durchsetzung der eigenen richtlinien so
die vorwürfe vieler kleinbauern
pedro kouadio der leiter des büros in
faro gesteht fehler ein
wir sind uns durchaus bewusst dass wir
nicht immer kontrollieren können wie
viel wasser auf den plantagen verwendet
wird viele plantagen besitzer haben gar
keine wasserzähler
es ist auch so dass landbesitzer das
risiko eingehen können plantagen einfach
zu bauen ohne genehmigung
es gibt eine gesetzeslücke es muss sich
etwas ändern
und doch ändert sich wenig vor allem
weil die strafzahlungen ein klacks sind
im vergleich zum profit den der avocado
anbau einbringt regelverstöße sind
entsprechend häufig und unter den laxen
kontrollen leiden vor allem menschen wie
die nächsten generationen was bleibt
ihnen noch an ressourcen nachdem diese
gierigen menschen weitergezogen sind das
einzige woran diese egoisten denken ist
geld profit lifestyle sie verteidigen
sich indem sie sagen sie ernährten uns
menschen ich weiß allerdings dass ich
ohne avocados leben kann aber nicht ohne
wasser
teams gut sprechen angst und sorge darum
wie es in zukunft weitergehen soll denn
es entstehen immer neue plantagen in
portugals sonnigen süden